foreign
[Music]
with analytics capability in immersive
stream for XR
you will be able to generate business
insights by understanding your customers
behaviors
in this tutorial I'm going to use a
cross-platform plugged in developed by
una media to demonstrate how to track
users interactions
I'm here with David who is the software
engineer of the plug-in and he's going
to walk you through practical use cases
David over to you hi I'm David a
software developer at unimedia and we
created a cross-platform plugin based on
the measurement protocol to track user
interactions the plugin provides an easy
solution for real-time logging of
application and game events to Google
analytics with automatic logging of key
events and user sessions and a simple
API with blueprint nodes making it easy
to log custom events and transactions
the plugin sends data using ordinary
https requests this makes it extremely
portable and available on all platforms
supported by Unreal Engine
now let's imagine a scenario where we
are an automaker and we might want to
know what customization options are the
most popular and which combinations are
frequently chosen together for
manufacturing and inventory purposes for
this example we'll be using the Auto
demo that's included with the immersive
stream for XR template project
this is a simple example of a car
configurator experience where users can
customize and preview various options
and features of the vehicle in real time
we have already modified the UI widget
to include an option for upgrading the
audio system and added a couple of
variables for keeping track of the
current configuration
now let's walk through how to make this
happen with the plugin
first we'll look at the basic setup of
the plugin the plugin is available on
the Unreal Engine Marketplace who once
purchased open the Epic Launcher and
under the Unreal Engine section click on
the library Tab and scroll down to the
Vault this is where you can access
assets purchased on the marketplace to
install simply click install to engine
then choose the desired Target engine
version the template project I'm using
is based on unreal 4.27 so I'll choose
that
with the template project open we'll go
to the plugins browser and check that
the plugin is enabled
with the plugin enabled we'll open the
project settings and navigate to the
Google analytics MP Options under the
analytics section then we'll click on
the configure Now button
this will set the plugin as the default
analytics provider now we'll need to get
the tracking ID required to send the
data we'll go to the administration
panel of our analytics account and
create a new property
a property acts as a container for the
data sent by the application
after setting up the name and other
property details we'll click on show
Advanced options and check create a
universal analytics property
for the URL you can put the associated
website if any or like in this example
use a fake URL
finally we'll select the create a
universal analytics property only option
with that setup done we can now go ahead
and create the property
you should now see a page for the
created Property displaying a tracking
ID
copy the tracking ID and head back to
unreal
now under the build configuration
settings we can enter the tracking ID
into the corresponding field for each
build setting
once you are done entering the tracking
ID you'll be prompted to restart the
editor in order to apply the settings
and that's it now you can start using
the plugin to pass data to analytics to
verify that everything is configured
correctly we'll play the application in
the editor
now back on the analytics site we'll
open the real-time report section and go
to the events page
if everything is working you should see
the app session start and app session
end events these are some automatic
events reported by the plugin and can be
disabled if not required
keep in mind that it can take a few
minutes for data to come through to the
analytics site
now that's all working let's take a look
at how to record custom events for this
we'll open the Autos menu UI widget
blueprint and add a new event to record
when a paint color is selected
first we'll create a new function to
process the current configuration and
send the event
we have already added a new variable for
keeping track of the selected paint
color so first we'll use this to get the
name of the color
next we'll add a record structured event
node this is a function node provided
with the plugin for recording events
with Analytics
we'll configure the node with a custom
string for the event category and event
action
and for the event label we'll pass in
the color name
now back in the event graph we'll add
our new function and call it whenever
one of the paint buttons is clicked
to test our event we'll click play and
change the paint color a few times
back in analytics we can see our custom
event has been recorded
note by default analytics will create a
website data view for reporting for more
relevant reporting we recommend adding a
mobile app View
to do this simply go to the admin
section
click on create View and select the
mobile app option in the new view
settings
now let's say we want to track some more
data about the car configuration such as
whether or not the user has selected the
audio system upgrade for this we'll need
to add a custom Dimension to the
property we set up on analytics with the
property selected in the administration
panel we'll click on the custom
definition section under the property
and select custom dimensions
then we'll simply create a new custom
Dimension with a relevant name
once created we'll take a note of the
assigned index number as this will be
required to associate the data with the
custom Dimension when sending the event
to Analytics
back in unreal we'll update our function
to include the audio system preference
when recording the event
to do this we'll create a new event
attribute
for the keystring we'll type in CD
followed by the index number of our
custom dimension
then for the value we'll simply pass in
a string to identify the selected audio
system option
back in the event graph we'll call our
function when the audio system selection
buttons are pressed
now we'll test our event Again by
clicking play and changing the paint and
audio system options
back in analytics we'll need to create a
custom report to see our data under the
customization section we'll go to the
custom reports page and select new
custom report
for the report type we'll select flat
table
then for the dimensions We'll add the
event label so we can see the paint
color
and our custom Dimension we set up for
the audio system
for the metrics We'll add total events
finally We'll add a filter for our event
action name and save the report
after waiting a while and adjusting the
date range we can now see our recorded
events categorized by the paint and
audio system combinations as time goes
by and more users interact with the
configurator the more data will be
collected over time with this example we
might find that a popular combination is
red paint with an audio system upgrade
Beyond this if you need Advanced query
features you can also export the data
from Google analytics to bigquery for
further analysis
that'll be it from me now back to you
jet
thank you David and that's a wrap you
can find all relevant information links
and resources in the video description
down below
I hope you find this video useful and
I'm looking forward to seeing you in the
next video